[Musique]
le risque concret c'est d'attraper
effectivement un virus informatique
qu'on appelle un ensemble moire
aujourd'hui qui va bloquer le système
d'information donc il va bloquer
l'activité de la collectivité qui va
bloquer l'activité de l'hôpital
et collectivités manquent de maturité
pour comprendre un petit peu ce qu'on va
appeler le risque cyber les
collectivités pour les divines dans la
hauteur mais un petit peu en région
Île-de-France c'est assez global voilà
elles sont dans la bonne moyenne c'est à
dire qu'elles sont entre le témoin et le
C+ il se trouve surtout pas que je sois
satisfait d'un B+ ou dans ces mois qui
sont des notes qui sont relativement
intéressantes mais qui sont toujours
insuffisantes qui seront toujours
insuffisantes par rapport à l'activité
d'un cyberattaquant qui va toujours
toujours chercher la vulnérabilité pour
pouvoir l'exploiter et pour pouvoir
effectivement pénétrer votre système
[Musique]
le catalogue est né au mois de juin de
cette année aujourd'hui
pour donner un chiffre j'ai plus d'une
centaine d'opportunités sur un potentiel
de sur un potentiel de collectivité au
niveau des départements de 350 on a
signé des contrats de cyber assurance
d'accord avec quelques cultivités sur
dans les Yvelines et dans les dans les
Hauts-de-Seine l'idée c'est de reposer
sur quatre grands piliers de la sécurité
et faire de la faire de la prévention
ensuite c'est de faire de la protection
détection et réaction
[Musique]